hello everyone i'm rahman irani i work
as a developer advocate at google cloud
and i'm pleased to bring you a new
episode of architecting with google
cloud today we are going to be looking
at atar energy a leading electric
vehicle manufacturer in india and
specifically right speaking of electric
vehicles and two wheelers which ather
energy is known for
when you actually take the scooter and
zoom away you would seldom think of what
are the things that are happening you
know on the scooter itself and what kind
of data is flowing into the platform and
how do they create a unique experience
uh you know for their customers so i'm
pleased to welcome ram pavaraju who had
software and web technologies at
etherenergy welcome ram to the show
thanks a lot roman thanks for having me
here
uh so my name is ram bhav raju i had
software and web technologies here at
the energy so software covers the entire
length and breadth of what we do at
eighth right from our factory all the
way to the customer all the applications
what we built the platforms what we
maintain thanks ram for joining us so
let's get started with uh you know
learning a bit more about ether energy
and specifically if you could tell us
some of the unique features that you
bring uh to the market and since you had
a you know ringside view of the eevee
evolution that's across the country
could you share some of your thoughts on
that too
i'll start probably with ether energy
and just focusing more on what we
started this journey for so we started
uh to get a very good form factor out of
two wheeler vehicles uh so we wanted to
build an ev energy ecosystem and have a
great customer experience and have a
have a great product uh fitment into the
market and that's how the entire ether
energy is energy's
product started and and we truly believe
in customer experience and that's where
uh probably the first of the first of
its kind in a two-wheeler form factor
started at a trip and we had a feature
stuck right statistics navigation on a
7-inch start screen
we there are lots of two-wheelers out
there in india which which had this kind
of a screen but none of them had this
kind of a form factor of touchscreen and
we had a
navigation uh turn button navigation on
top of it uh we had uh right statistics
uh using your companion app and also on
your touchscreen on your vehicle
you have something like uh like your
side stand detection which gives you an
indication if your side stand is open
when you're uh when you're riding your
vehicle
so on and so forth lots of these unique
features have uh uh are
probably the first of its kind in the
market uh itself coming from either
and now that the market has been
quite evolving in the last two three
years specifically uh
backed up by a central government policy
called fame fast adaption for uh both
hybrid and electric vehicles and the
latest version of it was version 2 which
was released in uh 2020
that kind of catapult the entire uh
demand part of things for an oem right
uh to to make to ensure that tvs come
into the 4a in the main fourier of the
two-wheeler segment that kind of a
demand was really really helpful and
fame subsidy uh really helped us
uh like gather lots of momentum and
that's where lots of electric vehicles
also manufacturers also started coming
into the picture
great so you you know you mentioned the
various features that you've already
built for example the side stand the
right characteristics etc so i can
almost imagine the kind of data that's
continuously going you know of every
single vehicle which you are then sort
of analyzing
and even giving near time real feedback
to the
customer or the driver in this case so
if you could just give us a bit of an
overview in terms of uh you know the
sheer scale of the data platform that
you would have to build out and how
google cloud platform has helped you do
that that's it's a very good question uh
to help everyone understand uh also what
does that
electric vehicle do just just look at
the form factor of two wheelers in this
case because of obviously the eighth
energy rate uh we have 50 plus sensors
uh within our vehicle and they they keep
sending data at different frequencies at
a large volume the frequency at which
they send uh we kind of gather all the
data uh and a five second intervals and
start sending it uh
into the cloud and we have a fleet of
20k plus vehicles out there on the road
right and and think about 20k plus
vehicles on the road sending almost also
500 600 variables at a five second
interval
it it becomes like uh if i just do the
basic mathematics it's gigabytes from
each of these vehicles turns into
terabytes of information on monthly
basis and our cold storage right now
runs into petabytes why do we collect
such such uh such volume of data is is
about because uh
as as i was pointing towards all the
unique features what we are building
right like for example if i look at
write statistics i need to understand
how did you how i i need to understand
how did your right go and then probably
present it back to you as a customer in
a way where you could consume it because
for an average customer average rider in
this case right they would not
understand all the fancy things
happening within the electric vehicle we
have to convert that all this data all
this useful like all this raw data under
useful information
and doing this at near real time is is
had been the biggest challenge and that
is where we are
kind of trying to solve all these
problems
thanks ram into uh giving us an insight
in terms of how the data is collected
and processed uh what i'd like to do
next is to straight away dive into the
architecture so if you could explain to
us uh like right from the time a scooter
takes off you know what's the kind of
requests or data that's flowing in from
the vehicle into the cloud platform what
are the different components there that
you are using of gcp and how does this
whole thing uh you know uh
come alive so since uh like we started
with this write statistics and the
entire audit as a shared volume of data
i'll take those two as an example and
then probably walk you through the
architecture
uh leaving the living what happens
inside the vehicle let's see the data is
now pushed to an mqtt broker uh what we
call it as an iot broker internet of
things broker all the vehicles start
publishing data into this broker and
this broker then publishes further up
into our kafka cluster
and this artemis broker's main
role is just to send data
from uh like the vehicles all the way
into a cluster where the majority of the
processing of this huge volume of data
is happening and all of these workloads
are currently running on gk once the
data comes into kafka we have both the
both the words that is the streaming
part of kafka we also use the the
consumers or probably the published
subscribe part of the kafka when we
looked at those uh the volume of data
what is coming in right when i said
about gigabytes terabytes and most of
the petabytes for cloud storage so 70
plus percent of our use cases are the
raw data itself so this is where it kind
of gives you insights like product
metrics gives you insight into
diagnostics of the vehicle or probably
look at service and support
and also a lot into the research and
development of the vehicles itself
and because it's so important for every
of these units to come together the raw
data processing is also the
quintessential essential for us right so
that is where we kind of use this uh
node pools which are within the ka
clusters and we use lots of consumers in
that case uh all this data gets
processed to a certain extent and then
get pushed into google cloud storage
we use data proc and data flow to a
large extent to query this data i was
talking about all these internal use
cases of uh
diagnostics or internal use case of r d
research and development of things for
that we use data data proc and data flow
and we kind of
use both these uh tools uh to process
the data and also query the data to a
large extent now now that this is the
raw data part of it uh now let's let's
look at something like a right statistic
which is about 20 30 of your the use
cases
this 20 to 30 percent of use cases
are more uh what do you say are more
realistic in this sense because these
are this is you have to do real-time
analysis you have to do real-time
processing of this data and this and
then push it further into an upstream
something like a real-time database
called as firebase where all of our apps
are like reading this data from so we
have ether app ethernet
like an ownership app which the
customers would be able to see
the vehicle information on their app
uh this real-time analytics again
requires lots of streaming of data so
all these messages which are coming in
hundreds of thousands and runs into
billions or a period of day or two
all this data gets processed in near
real time and then gets pushed into
firebase which then
pushes that data into the ether and
that's where the customers are able to
see the right statistics again we also
use some amount of bad jobs over there
and that is where we use data proc or
spark streaming what we call it as and
stream the data using those batches
thanks for you know
taking us through the entire request in
terms of how you know you're getting the
data you're further enriching it and
then the various applications uh that
are actually using this data to provide
both near real-time feedback also to the
user but the scale that you mentioned
right i just wanted to bring that up
again i'm sure there would have been you
know an instant or two where probably
some things didn't go right so could you
maybe just take listeners through maybe
an instance where there was an issue and
how you overcame that
issues are common right and that's where
the software teams
would learn right
so we ran into this issue of exhausting
the node pools
so gk runs on a concept of a cluster
which is
made of multiple different
notebooks not polish
or parts what we call them as part of
like a single unit which runs
any application per se in this case
let's take an example of a kafka
consumer which is nothing but an
application which consumes the data from
kafka
and does some action
and we ran out of node pool uh
uh on gk that because gk is a very good
uh hybrid of uh
open source like using uh jacob needs
but also has a managed services the
dental entire control plane is managed
by uh gcph and google cloud platform
itself in this case right uh the node
pools obviously have this concept of
auto scaling so we ran into place where
one of our major consumers and it has
a big work pool load that's about almost
about 180 node pools in that case was
trying to auto scale itself and it ran
out of nodes and what happened was that
uh now when you once you run out of the
resources that is you exhausted the
entire note pool you have to wait until
you get any backup in this case what
happened was that we are in that region
within india but uh we did not do
multi-zone clustered at that point in
time because we wanted uh majority for
workflows for running on a single zone
at that that case right
the entire node pool went into something
called as a recovery mode because the
control plane thinks that okay someone
is trying to scale up way beyond the
node's actual limits and now you don't
know what to do with it because you can
you're not able to do that
then then the cluster finds out saying
that okay i don't have enough resources
now i have to
fix it because i have to allocate the
existing resources itself right
something like that happened
and it took about 12 to 14 hours for us
to recover from that
luckily or the good the good part of
that was that none of the public facing
north poles were down but obviously from
an engineering use case uh for for
anyone to access this gke cluster we
have to go through go via
the control plane what we call it as the
cube uh ctlv that is the terminal window
where we
log in and look at our node pools and
resources so on and so forth we were we
weren't able to access it but luckily uh
we had a very good support from the
google product team to help us resolve
the issue
eventually we found out that there is a
way to uh work with this the cluster
management is
why i have this control plane to
like share the loads between the zones
and then we started getting into that
kind of conversations with the google uh
platform support specialist and and it
was
while it was very challenging because
obviously 12 hours
usa software team has panicked saying
that i'm not able to look at what is
happening in my own production
but eventually it's it's a good learning
curve because that's where we also got
to know lots of these
important things what we do on the cloud
platform that was an interesting
challenge and thanks tom for taking us
into how you addressed it uh what i
wanted to do now is actually go back to
the vehicle itself and earlier you
mentioned that there's a device that's
running on the vehicle itself right at
the edge so if you could tell us a
little bit more about the features of
the device that is still on the vehicle
so vehicle intelligence
as a platform if i put that word across
right so we we we are trying to make a
digital twin the vehicle and the cloud
almost having uh like similar or more
functionalities but there are
limitations in terms of vehicle just
because of the hardware limitations and
also the form factor what you can fit
within the vehicle and that's a very
fact that the intelligence is like a
little bit of
what you say compact in that sense we
have multiple layers within the vehicle
itself we have the dashboard layer which
is the human machine interface or hma
what we call it which has a ui app
which is built on android platform
then we have applications which are
supporting this hmi and also taking lots
of intelligent steps so we have data
intelligence as a library or an
application which runs which takes
informed decision of informed decisions
around
like i'll give a feature like a right
auto indicator turn off so auto
indicator turn off
is something which you would have seen
in a car
and automatically as soon as you take it
on it it gets back uh the lever pulls
back
a similar kind of a thing uh in a two
wheeler vehicle and probably you have
not heard or seen about it right that
that one thing as an intelligent
platform we were able to build because
of these sensors uh water
within the vehicle we are able to get
the data and auto turn off the
indicators and these are some of those
features which are the data intelligence
platform is building
and that's that's where that
data intelligence of service which is
inside the vehicle then we have a layer
called as a networking layer or the edge
device which is right at the top of all
the layers within the vehicle right and
this is the one which uh takes care of
your entire connection to the upstream
that is your cloud connect connecting to
the cloud or what we call it as a b2x uh
or vehicle to the cloud
in this case this is that edge device
arranged application which sits right on
the networking layer and sends this data
to the rtms broker what we spoke about
during the the cloud side of things
it also takes care of one very very
important or salient features and that's
the reason we call it as an intelligent
or data intelligent in this case right
it
because we have a 4g sim inside the
vehicle and you're roaming around and
there's like a data connection which is
being there not there
and in the situation where the data
connection is not there uh this edge
application starts uh storing the data
within the vehicle
and and now the challenge is that how
how long can it start because you're
talking about terabytes and gigabytes
terabytes and petabytes on the cloud
right
it's that's where the intelligence part
of things
comes into the picture it can store up
to 21 days of data then we also have
very very important application called
as a shadow application or probably a
vehicle uh in make an application we
call vehicle app
this trans transforms all the data which
is coming uh from the internal uh units
or the the control units within this
electric vehicle
and sends it to the edge device or edge
application and sets it upwards to the
cloud it kind of gets all the data and
publishes to this edge application which
which further publishes up into the
cloud
similarly it also we also have a very uh
like salient feature called as feature
plug management system which is like uh
like a system which kind of manage all
the features
outside the vehicle like for example a
a customer comes to our stage and says
that hey i want to do a different
subscription plan or change add more
features uh turn on more features inside
my vehicle right and that is available
right now at this point in time where we
will send that
back into the vehicle and this vehicle
app is the one which is kind of getting
those commands and transforming that
into those control units in the language
they understand or probably in the
command they would understand and so all
these layers are stacked up that way you
have the edge device it's sitting right
on the edge then you have the dashboard
which is sitting on the vehicle and
informing the customer take some
informed decisions then you have this
entire data intelligence which is kind
of reading the data and making more
informed decisions within the vehicle
and also sending it upwards then the
in-way club or the shadow which is kind
of talking both both ways that is to the
cloud and from the cloud and sending
further down into the different
units within the eev thanks tom for
helping us understand the kind of
intelligence that's built in every uh
you know energy vehicle
uh now if i just look at the whole
platform and where you are there right
now in terms of the features when you
started off right to build out these
platform there must be certain i would
say characteristics or certain kind of
features or the way you would want this
platform to have turned out in the
future
and what were some of those you know
technology decisions that you had to
make at that point in time
even in terms of the vision you had for
the product and how has google cloud
platform helped you achieve that
obviously the top of the list is uh like
cutting down the cost as you scale so
when you're a thousand two thousand
vehicles are like a starter
uh you would always think about how do i
go fast out there but once you start
moving from two thousand
ten thousand twenty thousand and upwards
right you have to cut down the cost cost
was one of our major uh things and
that's why gcp was very very helpful in
fact the entire case or gke is is quite
good in terms of optimized workloads
like uh auto scaling the like auto
scaling uh features so they're right to
increase the workload reduce the
workloads on demand
and something like preemptable virtual
missions or pvms what we call them as uh
to be attached to these workloads which
which inherently saves lots of cost in
that sense right
so we were able to balance all these
tools all these uh managed services
together and one of the key things about
this uh information of
uh being there on google cloud platform
is did the kind of uh awareness around
the open source platform and the
technologies what gcp brings in
so uh and we have a blend of very good
open source technologies and we also
have enterprise level support for those
technologies and that that's a good
blend of things right so that's where
inherently uh
gcp understands the needs of the
customers to a large extent and that's
that's one of the key things for any
any company to take this conversion a
decision not just theater uh because
you'll have also something called as a
community support so you have this
expert support in terms of how to run
systems and then you have this community
support to how to build systems so you
need both the worlds together right so
because uh until both the worlds are
like seamlessly working together it's
very very
tough to have that kind of uh like uh
what do you say uh uh
a marriage in this case right to run the
entire uh production systems out there
and that's why gcpa was very very very
helpful and that that kind of maturity
in terms of understanding the open
source platforms and getting them into
this the mainstream of managed services
so i'll give a very very uh
like clear example in this case we were
looking at a hive metastore to be
available as a managed service within
gcp and luckily or probably google also
was thinking about the same thing and
gcp was ready saying that hey hive
metastore is now
generic availability you don't have to
go and build it like a workload within
gk we have a ga or genetic availability
it mean that we can turn on the service
whenever we want it so that that kind of
gives a very good example of uh how
google kind of helps and listen to the
customers in this case and being very
proactive in terms of understanding
those open source technologies and
bringing them into
a good product segment thanks ram for
this and uh you know this brings us to
the end of this
episode thank you ram so much for
joining us
on this episode and sharing your
knowledge about the platform
thanks a lot roman thanks a lot for this
opportunity and i really appreciate uh
taking your time and asking me all these
questions
great so folks if you've uh you know
like this episode uh
you know click on like as well as
subscribe uh please do leave us some
comments uh you know in terms of any
future episodes that you would like to
see thank you so much for joining us
today on another episode of architecting
with google cloud see you next time
[Music]